what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic Wonder it's been a little
bit but we have a new Jonathan Majors
update that gives us a little bit of
hope that Jonathan Majors is going to
remain Kang the Conqueror in the MCU
provided he is innocent and wins his
court case now if you're not aware
Jonathan Majors Creed 3 star and Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania star who plays
King the Conqueror the Marvel Cinematic
Universe was arrested a few months ago
on accounts of assault against his now
ex-girlfriend his girlfriend at that
time since he was arrested his lawyer
and himself have stated that he is
completely innocent in this situation
and he in fact is the victim of the
whole thing now after he was arrested he
was released not too long after and is
now facing several charges of assault
against his ex-girlfriend the first date
for the trial has already begun Jonathan
Majors appeared in person and his lawyer
stated that they thought the court was
going to dismiss the case based off of
all of the evidence that they provided
to the court now we'll talk more about
this in a bit but first let's go over
his standing with with Marvel Studios
Jonathan Mages was set to be the big bad
the next Thanos of the entire MCU for
the next couple of faces Phase 5 and
phase six that was it he is the big bad
of the Multiverse Saga however since
Jonathan Majors was arrested and these
charges are being held against him he is
lost a lot he's lost some acting roles
his management company and his PR
Company both dropped him he's been
dropped from promotions and some
commercials that he's been doing and as
you can imagine right now his career has
come to a halt and right now A lot of
people are looking at Marvel Studios
wondering what they are going to do with
Jonathan Majors betraying King the
Conqueror and the MCU are they going to
replace him as king the Conqueror bring
in another actor to play the role of
King the Conqueror even though we
already got that Ant-Man and the WASP
post-credits scene where we saw over a
thousand Jonathan Majors playing a
thousand different variants of King to
conqueror but nevertheless if Jonathan
Majors is found as guilty Marvel Studios
might not really have a choice but to
replace simmers came the Conqueror or
pivot away from King the Conqueror being
so important in the Multiverse Saga that
may sound like it's a pretty crazy idea
however we recently learned about a
month ago that Kang originally wasn't
the primary focus of the multiversaga
but when Marvel Studios saw Jonathan
Majors portray he who remains and then
Kang and Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania they decided to Center the
multiversaga around him and make him the
absolute big bad villain having him
appear in many different movies and
possible Series so it wasn't originally
Marvel Studios plan to have Kang be such
a big factor of the Multiverse Saga they
could revert back to that although I
would argue now that we have the title
of Avengers the King Dynasty it's
probably a little too late however like
I mentioned we have some good news today
while all of this was happening with
Jonathan Majors Marvel Studios kind of
hid Jonathan majors in their promotions
in fact when they were promoting Ant-Man
and the wasp quantumania in all
descriptions of the film they simply
said the villain or they referred to a
threat they didn't even say King the
Conqueror in a lot of cases and then we
found out that Marvel Studios delayed
indefinitely the release of Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania assembled the
making of the film and fans got kind of
worried because this clearly showed that
the situation of Jonathan Majors was
affecting some aspects of Marvel and of
course it does Marvel Studios has to
decide what they are going to do well in
a good fortunate turn of events they
have actually released the assembled
making up special for Jonathan Majors
they didn't really announce this at all
didn't really promote it at all they
simply released it on Disney plus but if
you take a look it is there which is a
great sign because they did not have to
release this with everything going on
with Jonathan Majors they definitely
could have chose to not release this or
simply could have edited it a little bit
more to not have that much of Jonathan
majors's Kang in this special that they
released however if you watch it there
is a great deal of Jonathan majors in it
and even the description actually speaks
highly of Jonathan majors and again
before his name wasn't to be found
anywhere except for the credits because
they rightfully had to give him credit
as the actor that plays King the
Conqueror but check out what they had to
say with him the description of course
is assembled the making of Ant-Man and
the WASP of pontomania the description
is pretty long of course it talks about
talking to the cast of Crew looking at
interviews behind the scene footage etc
etc talking to Paul Rudd Evangeline
Lilly the rest of the cast Corey stole
his Modoc but then it says this but of
course when it comes to baddies the main
attraction is none other than Kang the
Conqueror heavyweight performer Jonathan
Majors opens up about the unique
processes he used to fully embody Marvel
Studios as next monstrous adversary all
of this and more await viewers and
assembled the making of Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania that is some pretty
High Praise from a studio that really
wasn't mentioning his name before or
promoting their new villain after
everything happened with Jonathan Majors
this could possibly mean that things are
turning around for Jonathan majors and
could be a great indicator that Marvel
Studios does in fact want to keep him as
came the Conqueror in fact I know they
want to keep him if he is proven
innocent because if he's proven innocent
there's no reason to punish him for
anything a lot of people and companies
have already done that before hearing
the entire story and a lot of evidence
has come out since he was arrested and I
think the fact that Jonathan majors has
provided such a large amount of evidence
in his favor to prove him innocent is
why right now Marvel Studios is okay
releasing the assembled making of
Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania and has
held off about making any type of rash
decision about firing Jonathan majors
and replacing King the Conqueror until
the court actually rules because you
know since all of this has happened
Jonathan majors has met with Marvel
Studios he's met with Kevin feige
possibly Bob Iger and explained
everything that has happened and I'm
sure once he gathered all of this
evidence he he went to Marvel Studios
and said hey this is me trying to show
you I am innocent I did not assault her
she assaulted me there's a lot of video
evidence there's photographic evidence I
have a lot of witnesses who are willing
to testify in court that I did not
assault her and there's even evidence of
her Harding immediately after the event
in which she said she got hurt but was
not evidently hurt in any of the videos
or photos that were taken of her
immediately after and that's what
happened a lot of the evidence that
Jonathan majors has is what I just
mentioned there is CCTV Street footage
of Jonathan Majors getting out of the
car in which we can see his ex pulling
him back in the car and kind of hitting
him but he actively tries to get out of
the car and run away from the situation
in which he does but people even see him
on the street and ask him to take a
photo in which he still obliges them and
takes the photo with them and then
continues to run away his ex-girlfriend
stays in the car and leaves the driver
of the vehicle at the time which was a
hired driver service is also one of the
people that is going going to testify
stating that Jonathan Majors never
attacked her Jonathan Mages returned to
his apartment the next morning around 10
or 11 A.M he went into his bedroom and
could not open the door so he called the
supervisor to open the door in which he
did and they both saw his girlfriend at
the time now his ex passed out drunk
half naked in his closet then Jonathan
Majors himself called the police and
when the police showed up since
everything was the way it was she was
seemingly injured they arrested Jonathan
Majors however the police were wearing
body cams and in the body cam you can
hear her say how did I get hurt she
herself didn't even remember at the time
and it is said that some of the
policemen there coached her to say that
it was Jonathan Majors that assaulted
her this footage has not been released
to the public yet but according to his
lawyer in the evidence they have
provided to the court that is what
happened so I would like to say that
Jonathan majors and his team took all of
this evidence all of this footage the
photos everything they have the witness
testimonies everything and showed it to
Marvel Studios and said hey this is me
trying to prove my innocence please
don't make any decision until the court
makes a decision because I would love to
remain came the Conqueror of course he
would and who knows what's going to
happen but like I mentioned he does have
a lot of evidence in his favor so much
evidence that his lawyer thought they
were going to throw out the case dismiss
it and simply state that Jonathan Majors
is Innocent but they are going to court
the next court date is August 3rd so if
we hear anything in the meantime we'll
be sure to do an update so don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
Bell so you can stay up to date on this
situation and of course Marvel Cinematic
Universe please give the video a like
and don't forget to subscribe and leave
a comment so you can enter our giveaway
for a chance to win an Xbox series X of
PS5 some Marvel Legends items or some DC
items we pick a winner at the end of
each month and the winner gets to pick
one item you can also check us out on
patreon you can check out our website
and Discord server and of course you can
follow us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof